其他人:给你一拳
Others: Give you a punch.
Jake:走走走走走走
Jake: Move, move, move, move, move.
Jake:就是这个
Jake: This is it.
Jake:哈哈哈傻屌
Jake: Hahaha, dumbass.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahaha.
Shure: 然后有的时候还打
Shure: And sometimes they even...
Shure: 完啊跑对
Shure: Finished, run, right.
Jake:你要穿
Jake: You need to wear...
Jake:你要穿模
Jake:你会穿模吗
Jake: Do you know how to wear...
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
其他人:我操这是他妈的这个沙雕
Others: Holy shit, this is that damn idiot from TikTok.
其他人:抖音上的短视频居然出现我眼前
Others: The short video on TikTok is right in front of me.
其他人:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Others: Hahahahahahaha.
Jake:都录了录着了录着了
Jake: It's all recorded, it's all recorded.
Jake:都有我第一视角就沙雕
Jake: Everything, my first-person view, just an idiot.
Lucia:啊也是啊
Lucia: Ah, true.
其他人:哈哈我好奇我们到时候音频要传吗
Jake:传啊这个都传
Jake: Upload it, upload everything.
其他人:我总感觉这音频要自己
Others: I feel like the audio will...
其他人:这音频到时数据一清洗
Others: The audio will get cleaned up later.
其他人:全洗完了
Others: All washed up
其他人:哈哈哈残缺不全
Others: Haha, incomplete
Shure: 还有什么比较适合走啊
Shure: What else is good to walk in?
Shure: 这个也适合
Shure: This one works too.
Katrina: 有点像跳popping的
Katrina: Looks a bit like popping.
Katrina: 哈哈什么都精通啊就说
Katrina: Haha, mastering everything, just saying.
Katrina: 真假正牛
Katrina: Real or fake, that's impressive.
Jake:缺点墨镜这倒是
Jake: Missing some sunglasses, though.
Shure: （歌词）乍风倦我日夜想万众凝望悲愤愤怒
Shure: (Lyrics) The sudden wind tires me, day and night I think, the crowd gazes with anger and sadness.
Shure: （歌词）不需往后独行
Shure: (Lyrics) No need to walk alone anymore.
Shure: （歌词）我定我写自我的法律
Shure: (Lyrics) I set and write my own rules.
Jake:这些车牌号都得干掉
Jake: All these license plates need to be removed.
Jake:我靠哈哈好烦呐
Jake: Damn, haha, so annoying.
Jake:对啊对啊
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Jake:就要干掉嘛
Jake: They need to be removed.
（歌词）哎我昨天还看季坤在在朋友圈发
(Lyrics) Hey, I saw Ji Kun post in his moments yesterday.
（歌词）他用那个Inter VL啊
(Lyrics) He used that Inter VL.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
（歌词）然后两辆车一辆宝马一辆奔驰啊
(Lyrics) And two cars, a BMW and a Mercedes.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
（歌词）然后那个标就是那种巨小的那种啊
(Lyrics) And the logo was tiny.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
（歌词）然后他就问Inter VL说
(Lyrics) Then he asked Inter VL.
（歌词）这辆这个宝马车车牌号多少啊
(Lyrics) What's the license plate number of this BMW?
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
（歌词）他会卧槽OK
(Lyrics) He was like, whoa, okay.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
（歌词）你就是应该往这走
(Lyrics) You should be heading this way.
（歌词）卡在这卡在这
(Lyrics) Stuck here, stuck here.
Jake:你卡在两侧中间对
Jake: You're stuck in the middle on both sides.
Shure: 或者NF直接进入载具吧我还是
Shure: Or NF, just get in the vehicle, I guess.
Jake:谢丽哈哈
Jake: Shelly, haha.
Jake:谢丽哈哈哈哈哈哈一路抖音吗
Jake: Shelly, hahaha, all the way on Douyin?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: （歌词）他们朝我扔泥巴
Shure: (Lyrics) They throw mud at me.
Shure: （歌词）我拿泥巴种荷花
Shure: (Lyrics) I plant lotus flowers with it.
Lucia:从未觉得这么平凡的一条路
Lucia: Never thought such a simple road.
Jake:是啊
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia:能有这么多的危险
Lucia: Could have so many dangers.
Shure: 平凡的路这平凡吗
Shure: Is this ordinary road really ordinary?
Lucia:不平凡吗
Lucia: Isn't it extraordinary?
Shure: 我曾经跨过山和大海
Shure: I've crossed mountains and seas
Lucia:也走过人山人海
Lucia: And walked through crowds of people
哈哈
*laughing*
Shure: 我曾经拥有过的一切
Shure: I've had everything I once owned
哈
*laughing*
Shure: （歌词）我曾经像你像他像那野草野花
Shure: (Lyrics) I was once like you, like him, like wild grass and flowers
Shure: 这个口音一定要模仿到位
Shure: You have to mimic the accent perfectly
Shure: （歌词）几道间平凡
Shure: (Lyrics) Through several turns, it's ordinary
Shure: 朴树
Shure: Pu Shu
Jake:回头率不低啊
Jake: Turning heads, huh?
Jake:走我们去我们去给他们祝贺一下
Jake: Let's go, let's go congratulate them
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha
Lucia:哈哈哈你起什么社交恐怖分子了
Lucia: Hahaha, what kind of social terrorist are you now?
Jake:哈哈哈这几个像伪装起来
Jake: Hahaha, these guys look like they're in disguise
Jake:哈比夫人哈哈哈跟缩油似的哈哈哈
Jake: Haha, Mrs. Hobbit, hahaha, like shrinking oil, hahaha
哈哈哈
*laughing*
Shure: 今天你生日
Shure: It's your birthday today
Shure: 送给你祝福
Shure: Here's my blessing for you
Shure: 哒哒
Shure: Da da
其他人:（歌词）哒哒哒我们相亲又相爱
Others: (Lyrics) Da da da, we love and cherish each other
Shure: （歌词）跟所有的烦恼说拜拜
Shure: (Lyrics) Say goodbye to all the troubles
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahaha
Shure: 说嗨嗨
Shure: Say hi hi
Jake:我错了哈哈哈哈
Jake: I was wrong, hahaha
Lucia:啊过了吗
Lucia: Ah, did we pass?
Jake:没有没有他错了
Jake: No, no, he was wrong
Lucia:气死
Lucia: So annoying
Jake:对了对了对了哈哈
Jake: Yes, yes, yes, haha
Lucia:大家都是社交恐怖分子是吧
Lucia: Everyone's a social terrorist, right?
Jake:对我我我们一排爱人
Jake: Yes, we are all lovers in a row
Jake:哈哈哈你觉得我信吗哈哈
Jake: Haha, do you think I believe that? Haha
Lucia:你觉得我信吗
Lucia: Do you think I believe it?
Jake:月亮
Jake: The moon
Shure: （歌词）里呀嘛更儿里呀
Shure: (Lyrics) Li ya ma geng er li ya
Shure: （歌词）月牙照花台
Shure: (Lyrics) The crescent moon shines on the flower terrace
Jake:耶唱歌呢
Jake: Yeah, singing
Jake:对今儿周末应该挺多是闲人
Jake: Yes, it's the weekend, there should be quite a lot of idle people
Shure: （歌词）早知如此何必开始
Shure: (Lyrics) If I had known it would end like this, why did it start?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha.
Shure: 我怕你们不接我了哈哈哈
Shure: I was afraid you guys wouldn't pick me up, haha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈那问题也不大是不是
Jake: Hahaha, but it's not a big deal, is it?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia:这么大个人了
Lucia: Such a big person already.
Lucia:反正不会丢哈哈
Lucia: Anyway, you won't get lost, haha.
Shure: 怕我怕我怕我怕我的屁股不保
Shure: I'm afraid, I'm afraid, I'm afraid my butt won't be safe.
Shure: 你干什么
Shure: What are you doing?
Shure: 谢郡主
Shure: Thank you, Princess.
Shure: 你要你要你要你要你要你要揪我屁股
Shure: You want, you want, you want, you want, you want to pinch my butt.
Jake:哈哈哈什么东西
Jake: Hahaha, what is this?
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha.
Jake:记一下记一下记一下记一下记一下
Jake: Note it down, note it down, note it down, note it down, note it down.
Jake:哈哈秀秀这单你自己解
Jake: Haha, Shure, you handle this one yourself.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia:左拐啊左拐
Lucia: Turn left, turn left.
Jake:对对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes, yes.
其他人:你们要剪就都保留走
Others: If you want to cut it, keep everything.
Shure: 随便
Shure: Whatever.
Shure: 到时候就是语音识别问题这一段
Shure: Then it will be a voice recognition issue in this section.
其他人:这一段你说呗
Others: You talk about this section.
Jake:他收音挺好的
Jake: It records well.
Jake:呵呵呵对
Jake: Hehe, yes.
Jake:因为他就在你脸上了
Jake: Because it's right in front of your face.
18:51修说几只
18:51 Shure said a few.
19点你就修说逆天哈哈
At 19:00, Shure said it was against the sky, haha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
其他人:12:21危险言论
Others: 12:21 dangerous speech.
Jake:哈哈哈哈危险言论
Jake: Hahaha, dangerous speech.
Jake:不管不管
Jake: Whatever, whatever.
Jake:到时候看吧
Jake: We'll see then.
Shure: 慢慢削吧你们就
Shure: You guys just slowly trim it.
Jake:对慢慢削吧
Jake: Yes, slowly trim it.
Shure: 我只负责生产数据
Shure: I only produce data.
Shure: 不负责处理数据
Shure: I don't process data.
Shure: 提上裤子警报
Shure: Pants up alert.
Shure: 哈哈哈没事没事
Shure: Hahaha, it's fine, it's fine.
Jake:擅长生产无用数据哈哈哈
Jake: Skilled at producing useless data, haha.
Jake:又有小车
Jake: Another small car.
Jake:准备FFF FF
Jake: Get ready, FFF FF
Jake:哈哈哈对
Jake: Haha, right
Jake:先拿一下站嘴边
Jake: Hold it near your mouth first
Jake:然后会停
Jake: Then it will stop
Jake:就是我们的姐姐
Jake: This is our sister
Jake:哈喽这是
Jake: Hello, this is
Jake:这是带我们的
Jake: She’s the one who brings us
Jake:对对就是送快递的姐姐
Jake: Yes, she’s the delivery sister
Shure: 这姐不会看的
Shure: She won’t watch this
Shure: 他直接会撞过去的
Shure: She’ll just go straight into it
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Shure: 他每次坐车呼呼开着就玩手机
Shure: Every time she’s in the car, she’s just playing on her phone
Shure: 你知道吗
Shure: You know?
其他人:你这个动作不对
Others: Your action is wrong
其他人:他带我说是两个手在玩手机
Others: She told me she uses both hands to play on her phone
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Jake:火
Jake: Fire
Shure: 师傅捎一段吧
Shure: Master, give us a ride
Shure: 咱们应该打车过去的
Shure: We should have taken a cab
Shure: 打辆商务哈哈哈
Shure: Get a business car, haha
Shure: 反正有经费
Shure: Anyway, we have the budget
Jake:欢庆春节
Jake: Celebrating the Spring Festival
Shure: 你滚
Shure: Get out
Shure: 你妈要是躺我旁边我都得做噩梦
Shure: If your mom was lying next to me, I’d have nightmares
Jake:昨天晚上睡觉动了吗
Jake: Did you move while sleeping last night?
Jake:我不知道OK
Jake: I don’t know, okay
Jake:哈哈哈你不会我
Jake: Haha, you wouldn’t
Jake:哈哈哈我真不知道
Jake: Haha, I really don’t know
Jake:哈哈哈我应该知道什么吧
Jake: Haha, should I know something?
其他人:因为我觉得我睡得很踏实啊
Others: Because I think I slept well
Shure: 啊我就是应该问健康
Shure: Ah, I should ask about health
Shure: 摸摸自己的屁股疼吗哈哈哈
Shure: Does your butt hurt? Haha
Jake:你再你再挤一条
Jake: Squeeze out another one
Jake:你再挤一条
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Shure: 哎呀他得会这些东西
Shure: Oh, he has to know these things
Jake:哈哈哈你能不能不让学术
Jake: Haha, can you stop being academic
Jake:这些做学术的人做这东西
Jake: Do academic people do these things?
Shure: 做学术的人就没有吃喝拉撒吗难道
Shure: Don’t academic people eat, drink, and relieve themselves too?
Jake:有但是好像没有你说的这些东西
Jake: Yes, but it doesn't seem to have the things you mentioned.
Shure: 开玩笑那罗罗罗丽岛是吧
Shure: Are you kidding? That's Lorelei Island, right?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha
其他人:他妈的7.08-09全删完
Others: Damn, everything from 7.08 to 7.09 is deleted.
Lucia:嘴巴捂住
Lucia: Cover your mouth.
其他人:就揭开他们丑陋的面纱
Others: Just unveil their ugly masks.
其他人:不要一个个当
Others: Don't be one by one.
Lucia:我都不想出现在这个画符里了哈哈
Lucia: I don't even want to appear in this scene anymore, haha.
Shure: 反正我以后不搞学术
Shure: Anyway, I'm not going into academia.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha
Shure: 人家都是时间点
Shure: They have exact times.
Shure: 我这时间段是吧
Shure: I have time periods, right?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:唱点能播的
Jake: Sing something that can be broadcasted.
Jake:哈哈完了哈哈哈
Jake: Haha, we're done, haha.
Shure: 能播的有啥的人
Shure: What's there that can be broadcasted?
Jake:没有
Jake: Nothing.
Jake:曲库里面没有
Jake: There's nothing in the music library.
Jake:不存在的
Jake: It doesn't exist.
Shure: 确实你要
Shure: Indeed, if you...
Shure: 说播点不能播
Shure: ...want to sing something that can't be broadcasted,
Shure: 我一下能给你唱10首
Shure: I can sing you 10 songs right away.
其他人:那你先唱吧我给你接着唱
Others: Then you start, and I'll follow.
Shure: 别了然后咱们取快递
Shure: No, then let's go pick up the package.
Shure: 不行取快递的这个珍贵影像就没了
Shure: No way, the precious footage of picking up the package will be lost.
其他人:你不仅要顶你一个人的眼镜
Others: You not only have to carry your own glasses,
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Shure: 之后就开始删微信了
Shure: Then start deleting WeChat.
Shure: 再见了家人们哈哈
Shure: Goodbye, family, haha.
Jake:再见了哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Goodbye, hahahaha
Lucia:哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha
Shure: 今天你生日
Shure: It's your birthday today.
Shure: 送给你祝福
Shure: Sending you my blessings.
Shure: 这什么地啊
Shure: What's this place?
Shure: 这不会是一个
Shure: Could it be...
Shure: 珐琅吧
Shure: ...enamel?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake:里面有人
Jake: There's someone inside.
Shure: 哟
Shure: Yo
Shure: 可不是吗
Shure: Isn't that right?
Shure: 居然有人
Shure: Can't believe someone
Jake:有好几个人
Jake: There are quite a few people
Jake:呵嗯
Jake: Hmm
Jake:好这翻译的
Jake: Wow, this translation
Shure: 这翻译的
Shure: This translation
Jake:我信不信达雅
Jake: I can't believe it
Shure: 就是信不信达雅吧就说
Shure: Yeah, it's unbelievable
Jake:这很难很难信
Jake: It's really hard to believe
Jake:很难不信达雅哈哈哈
Jake: Hard not to believe, haha
Shure: 真的我这可以实时转意
Shure: Seriously, I can translate in real-time
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Alright
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Okay
Shure: OK
Jake:如意看见没
Jake: Did you see that, Ruyi?
Jake:AF OK哈哈哈哈
Jake: AF OK, hahaha
Shure: if OK哈哈哈
Shure: If OK, hahaha
Jake:吉祥
Jake: Lucky
Shure: if come
Shure: If come
Shure: happy啊这个如意啊啊
Shure: Happy, this Ruyi, ah
Jake:啊吉祥如意
Jake: Ah, lucky and prosperous
其他人:follow your heart
Others: Follow your heart
其他人:我怎么感觉
Others: I feel like
其他人:都要走到那个什么卫生间了
Others: We're almost at the bathroom
Jake:就是那哦
Jake: Right there
Shure: i feel like we almost arrived
Shure: I feel like we almost arrived
Jake:哎锦州巷子里要
Jake: Hey, in Jinzhou alley
Shure: 有锦州烧烤
Shure: There's Jinzhou BBQ
Shure: 我们来这吃吧
Shure: Let's eat here
Jake:哈哈哈整点串吧
Jake: Hahaha, let's get some skewers
Shure: 闻着好香啊哈哈哈
Shure: Smells so good, hahaha
Jake:要不带点串回去吧要不
Jake: Why don't we take some skewers back?
Lucia:因为昨天那会已经是晚上了
Lucia: Because it was already night yesterday
Lucia:现在这个天色又不认识了
Lucia: And now it's daylight, so it's unrecognizable
Shure: 闻着好香啊
Shure: Smells so good
Jake:好香哦
Jake: So fragrant
Jake:你昨天直接走过来也挺挺远我感觉
Jake: You walked all the way here yesterday, it felt quite far
其他人:我草我也想吃
Others: Damn, I want to eat too
Lucia:我总觉得我昨天总是好像没这么远
Lucia: I keep feeling like it wasn't this far yesterday
Jake:主要旁边没别人
Jake: Mainly because there's no one else around.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahaha
Lucia:哈哈不是哈哈哈不是真不是
Lucia: Haha, no, no, not really.
Shure: 我靠
Shure: Oh my god.
其他人:你让我们时间变得很欢乐
Others: You make our time so joyful.
Lucia:对对对
Lucia: Yes, yes, yes.
Shure: 欢乐的时光不是总是短暂的吗
Shure: Isn't it that joyful times are always short?
其他人:欢乐的时光对
Others: Joyful times, right.
Lucia:他这小路挺多的
Lucia: There are so many small paths here.
Lucia:可能昨天走的不是同一个小路
Lucia: Maybe we took a different path yesterday.
Jake:就消耗比较大是吧
Jake: It's quite exhausting, isn't it?
Jake:对有点累
Jake: Yeah, I'm a bit tired.
Jake:嘟哒嘟
Jake: Doodadoo
Shure: 挺好挺好
Shure: Pretty good, pretty good.
Shure: 我今天放弃了
Shure: I'm giving up today.
Jake:羊汤馆
Jake: Lamb soup shop.
Shure: 卧槽对
Shure: Oh right.
Shure: 买了彩票
Shure: Bought a lottery ticket.
Shure: 走走走这个珍贵录像得记录一下
Shure: Let's go, let's go, we need to record this precious moment.
Jake:延吉冷面
Jake: Yanji cold noodles.
Jake:啊买彩票啊
Jake: Ah, bought a lottery ticket, huh?
Jake:真买彩票
Jake: Really bought one.
其他人:真买
Others: Really bought it.
Jake:看看看你刮彩票买买买
Jake: Let's see, scratch it, buy, buy, buy.
Shure: 要来一个这个 2020
Shure: Let's get one of these, 2020.
其他人:5050 来就来
Others: 5050, let's do it.
其他人:大的怎么这么少报销呢
Others: Why are the big ones reimbursed so little?
Jake:怎么这么
Jake: Why so...
Shure: 报销吗报销
Shure: Reimbursed, reimbursed?
其他人:报销不报啊
Others: Reimbursed or not?
Jake:报销刮彩票那
Jake: Reimburse for the lottery ticket then.
Jake:那你刮出来算啥啊
Jake: What if you win something?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈那那我自费一张20
Shure: Hahaha, then I'll pay for one, 20 yuan.
Shure: 来张20的
Shure: Give me a 20 yuan one.
其他人:这样吧你给我报
Others: How about this, you reimburse me.
其他人:50我还刮
Others: 50 and I'll scratch it.
其他人:刮出来钱都是你的
Others: Whatever I win is yours.
其他人:哈哈哈啊
Others: Hahaha
Jake:这么回事
Jake: Is that how it is?
Shure: 那个打打一注双色
Shure: Let's play a round of Double Color Ball.
Shure: 打50块钱双色球
Shure: Bet 50 yuan on Double Color Ball.
Shure: 然后那个
Shure: And then...
其他人:我靠你好老
Others: Wow, you're so old-school.
其他人:厉害啊哈
Others: Impressive, huh?
Shure: 号是一哎呀
Shure: The number is... Oh, man...
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Shure: 那个146
Shure: The red balls are 146.
Shure: 啊不不
Shure: Oh no, no...
Shure: 那个红球是146
Shure: The red balls are 146.
Shure: 然后15二七30
Shure: Then 15, 27, 30.
Shure: 然后篮球是
Shure: And the blue ball is...
Shure: 我看一眼
Shure: Let me take a look.
其他人:呵这是能算出来吗
Others: Can you really calculate this?
Jake:你别看你看什么菜单啊
Jake: Don't look, what are you checking the menu for?
Shure: 篮球双色图
Shure: The Double Color Ball chart.
Jake:你看那边篮球来一个
Jake: Look over there, a blue ball, pick one.
Shure: 来个5吧
Shure: Let's go with 5.
Jake:我靠
Jake: Wow.
Shure: 5倍对5倍
Shure: 5 times, yes, 5 times.
Shure: 总共30是吧
Shure: Total is 30, right?
Jake:牛批
Jake: Awesome.
其他人:那你戴眼镜
Others: Then you wear glasses.
Jake:不用不用不用
Jake: No need, no need.
Jake:不不不这么搞这么搞
Jake: No, no, let's do it this way.
其他人:但刮彩票可以很解压
Others: But scratching lottery tickets can be very stress-relieving.
其他人:如果刮出来就更解压
Others: If you win, it's even more stress-relieving.
其他人:来吧
Others: Come on.
其他人:刮出来了
Others: Got it.
其他人:刮出来就吸了来
Others: If you win, you get addicted.
其他人:最高奖金80万呢
Others: The top prize is 800,000 yuan.
Jake:啥意思
Jake: What does that mean?
其他人:就刮带这个带这个符号的
Others: You scratch the ones with this symbol.
其他人:哦这个符号是刮不出来的
Others: Oh, you can't scratch this symbol.
其他人:我觉得还有一个我的号码
Others: I think there's still my number.
其他人:对你先把你的号码刮出来
Others: Yes, scratch your number first.
其他人:中奖号码你的号码刮出来
Others: Winning number, scratch your number.
其他人:嗯那我也刮这个
Others: Okay, I'll scratch this too.
Lucia:哎我也刮一个吧
Lucia: Hey, I'll scratch one too.
其他人:快不行
Others: Hurry, it won't work.
Jake:其他人:
Jake: Everyone else:
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Shure: 1133
Jake:哎 50的
Jake: Hey, it's 50.
Jake:你这为什么更牛逼
Jake: Why is yours more awesome?
Shure: 他50的
Shure: He's got 50.
其他人:来就来大的
Others: Go big or go home.
其他人:你中了吗
Others: Did you win?
Jake:他有几个铲子啊
Jake: How many shovels does he have?
Shure: 323134 我这是金铲铲
Shure: 323134, mine is a golden shovel.
Jake:就一个铲子 34
Jake: Just one shovel, 34.
其他人:我这是金铲子
Others: Mine's a golden shovel.
Jake:呵呵呵不太像
Jake: Haha, doesn't seem like it.
其他人:他这个没中
Others: He didn't win.
其他人:记好回本了回本了
Others: Remember, we broke even, broke even.
其他人:回本我就必须得继续all in
Others: If I break even, I have to keep going all in.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha
Jake:啥意思啊
Jake: What does that mean?
Jake:啥意思
Jake: What does it mean?
其他人:他回本了
Others: He broke even.
Shure: 就是这个十一嘛
Shure: It's just this eleven.
Shure: 然后这又是十一
Shure: And then this is another eleven.
Jake:哦对了21哎
Jake: Oh yeah, 21, right.
Shure: 然后就获得这20
Shure: And then you get this 20.
Jake:哎呦这贵的就是快刮的
Jake: Oh, the expensive ones scratch off quickly.
其他人: 哦这些这些都能直接换钱
Others: Oh, these can all be exchanged for cash.
Jake:对啥意思
Jake: Right, what does that mean?
其他人:只要刮出来钱就是钱
Others: As long as you scratch off money, it's money.
Jake:这刮这么多钱啊
Jake: You can scratch off that much money?
其他人:就接就是得有彩才行
Others: Yeah, you need luck.
Jake:哦那给你写个数字干嘛呀
Jake: Oh, then why do they give you a number?
其他人:如果有彩就是下面的钱
Others: If you're lucky, that's the money below.
Jake:哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh.
Jake:是啥意思
Jake: What does it mean?
其他人:就是啥也没有
Others: It means nothing.
其他人:就是鸡的意思
Others: It just means a chicken.
Jake:哈哈哈哦
Jake: Haha, oh.
Jake:啊你这多少钱呢
Jake: Ah, how much did you get?
Lucia:出来一张
Lucia: One came out.
Jake:也是20 也是20
Jake: Also 20, also 20.
Shure: 确实
Shure: Indeed.
其他人:寄了我怎么感觉寄了
Others: I feel like it's sent.
Jake:你这50块钱怎么一
Jake: How come you have nothing with this 50 bucks?
Jake:毛都没有
Jake: Not a single hair.
其他人:50块钱寄了
Others: The 50 bucks are sent.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:好可以捐到50是吧
Jake: Okay, can we donate 50?
Jake:福利了我已经逐渐忍住捐了
Jake: I've almost held back from donating.
其他人: 我已经逐渐忍住捐了50
Others: I've almost held back from donating 50.
Katrina: 十跟19
Katrina: Ten and nineteen.
Lucia:19
Lucia: Nineteen.
Katrina: 啊 80万
Katrina: Ah, 800k.
Jake:啊这要看啥呀
Jake: Ah, what are we looking at?
Katrina: 不是这是下边
Katrina: No, it's below.
Katrina: 下边才是那个
Katrina: Below is the one.
Katrina: 吓我一跳哈哈哈
Katrina: Gave me a scare, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈发财了是吧
Jake: Hahaha, you think you struck it rich?
Shure: 一般写80万都不会中
Shure: Usually, if it says 800k, it won't win.
Katrina: 吓我一跳
Katrina: Gave me a scare.
其他人:但我觉得能刮到写80万的也很不容易
Others: But I think scratching one that says 800k is already something.
Katrina: 等一下
Katrina: Wait a moment.
其他人:已经开始激动了
Others: Already getting excited.
其他人:不是主要是我这一顿隐形眼睛
Others: It's mainly because I have this one contact lens.
Katrina: 不是主要是我只有一个隐形眼镜
Katrina: It's mainly because I only have one contact lens.
其他人:哦哦哦这样看着直接刮过了
Others: Oh, oh, oh, just scratched it directly.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina: 看不清
Katrina: Can't see clearly.
Jake:哦你你这个80万你特地不刮是吧
Jake: Oh, you're deliberately not scratching the 800k, right?
Jake:就是你最后再
Jake: You're saving it for last.
Jake:呵呵呵你最后等着
Jake: Haha, you're waiting until the end.
Katrina: 随缘吧我是多少啊
Katrina: Let it be, what's my amount?
Jake:十十是没有
Jake: Ten, ten is nothing.
Katrina: 10和19
Katrina: Ten and nineteen.
其他人:哇这中奖率好低啊
Others: Wow, the winning rate is so low.
Katrina: 确实图一乐
Katrina: Indeed, it's just for fun.
Jake:30哎
Jake: Thirty, hey.
Jake:没7 那是什么呀
Jake: No seven, what is that?
其他人:最上面那个
Others: The top one.
其他人:万一80万呢
Others: What if it's 800k?
Jake:万一就50中呢
Jake: What if it's just 50?
Jake:14 那80万
Jake: 14, that's 800,000.
Shure: 14最上面那个
Shure: 14, the top one.
Jake:80万看看
Jake: 800,000, let's see.
Jake:卧槽我靠
Jake: Whoa, damn.
其他人:哇塞差一点
Others: Wow, so close.
Jake:差一点差一点
Jake: So close, so close.
Jake:哎差点憋出一个哎
Jake: Almost held it in, almost.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈老板来一张这个啊
Jake: Hahaha, boss, take a picture of this, okay?
Jake:这里挂一晚上
Jake: Hang it here overnight.
Katrina:  在这挂一晚上
Katrina: Hang it here overnight.
Jake:哈哈哈老板还有多少张
Jake: Hahaha, boss, how many more do you have?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Shure: 我们经费熬夜
Shure: We're burning the budget.
Shure: 这个要么就明天卷铺盖回家
Shure: Either we stay up all night, or we pack up and go home tomorrow.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Shure: 要么我们就经费翻倍好吧
Shure: Or we double the budget, okay?
Jake:哈哈 80万是吧
Jake: Haha, 800,000, right?
其他人:哎好久不刮了
Others: Haven't scratched in a long time.
其他人:上一次刮可能还是两年之前
Others: The last time might have been two years ago.
其他人:没了
Others: No more.
Jake:哈哈哈但我压力很大了哈哈
Jake: Hahaha, but I'm under a lot of pressure now, haha.
其他人:2634
Others: 2634.
Shure: 34
Shure: 34.
Jake:这钱上哪领啊
Jake: Where do we claim this money?
Jake:直接直接给是吧哦
Jake: Just hand it over directly, right? Oh.
其他人:看日记没有
Others: Did you see the journal?
其他人:没有
Others: No.
Shure: 上次跟你同学去刮针刮出500
Shure: Last time, I went with your classmate, we scratched and won 500.
Shure: 他说500的是十十十十十十
Shure: He said the 500 ones are ten, ten, ten, ten, ten.
Shure: 就是全中那种
Shure: It's like hitting all of them.
其他人:哇那很厉害
Others: Wow, that's impressive.
其他人:捐了20福利
Others: Donated 20 to charity.
Jake:捐20
Jake: Donated 20.
Jake:好嘞福利好
Jake: Alright, charity is good.
Jake:福利福利
Jake: Charity, charity.
其他人:他中奖率也太低
Others: The winning rate is too low.
其他人:我之前看过有人刮一本
Others: I saw someone scratch a whole book before.
其他人:刮一本算那个算那个钱
Others: Scratching a whole book counts as money.
其他人:我操又有素材了啊
Others: Damn, more material!
Lucia:哈哈大家既然都买了我也跟一张
Lucia: Haha, since everyone bought one, I'll get one too.
Jake:先看下哪
Jake: Let's check first.
Jake:一个吧那我很难不买了
Jake: One, then I can't resist buying it.
其他人:那你跟一个
Others: Then you get one.
Jake:那我更个20的
Jake: I'll get one for 20.
其他人:跟个20
Others: Get one for 20.
Jake:这这红的红的和蓝色有什么差别吗
Jake: What's the difference between the red and blue ones?
Shure: 没有没有区别
Shure: There's no difference.
Jake:没有差别
Jake: No difference?
Lucia:我觉得我都好久
Lucia: I think it's been a long time.
Shure: 我都好久
Shure: It's been a long time.
Lucia:没玩过这个了
Lucia: Since I last played this.
Jake:好那我选一个
Jake: Okay, I'll choose one.
Lucia:但是哈哈
Lucia: But haha
Lucia:近有什么用呢
Lucia: What's the use of being close?
Lucia:哈哈哈像刚刚那个
Lucia: Haha, just like the previous one.
这这红的在刚刚刚刚那个80万麒麟是吧哈
This, this red one was the 800,000 Kirin just now, right? Haha.
Lucia:哎近有什么用呢
Lucia: What's the use of being close?
Shure: 差点出门就哈哈
Shure: Almost got out, haha.
其他人:差点差点差点差点就可以光荣的从这里离开了
Others: Almost, almost, almost could have left gloriously.
Jake:整个20了吧
Jake: Make it 20 then.
Shure: 20新币的吧整一个
Shure: 20 new dollars, make it one.
Jake:那不行整个20新币吧
Jake: No, make it 20 new dollars.
Jake:那那可不行
Jake: That's not okay.
Shure: 杨老板好好理智
Shure: Jake, be rational.
其他人:哎他中奖率好
Others: Hey, his winning rate is good.
其他人:我们连买了123四五张
Others: We bought 123 four, five tickets in a row.
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
其他人:对啊这概率有点低是吧哈哈好气
Others: Yeah, the odds are a bit low, right? Haha, so frustrating.
Jake:来来了来了来了来了来了
Jake: Come on, come on, come on, come on, come on!
Shure: 杨老板相信你
Shure: Jake, I believe in you.
Shure: 好中国有句古话叫做
Shure: There's an old Chinese saying...
Jake:屎屎哈哈哈
Jake: Shit, shit, haha.
Shure: 杨老板好干脆啊没有
Shure: Jake is so straightforward, no...
Jake:没
Jake: No.
Lucia:没有没有
Lucia: No, no.
Jake:没有
Jake: No.
其他人:哎哦没有
Others: Oh, no.
Jake:没有
Jake: No.
Shure: 哎呦没有
Shure: Oh, no.
Shure: 哎呦没
Shure: Oh no
Jake:没有
Jake: Nope
Jake:哎中了30
Jake: Oh hit 30
Shure: 18 哎呦哎呦哎呦哎呦赚10块
Shure: 18, oh wow, made 10 bucks
Jake:哎呦哎呦哎呦卖10块
Jake: Oh wow, sold for 10 bucks
Jake:哎呦来看看
Jake: Oh, let's take a look
Jake:招招18哎
Jake: 18, right
Jake:还是23是吧
Jake: Or was it 23?
Jake:是2327
Jake: It was 2327
其他人:很难中两个
Others: Hard to get two
其他人:很难中两好
Others: Hard to get two right
Jake:行吧
Jake: Alright
其他人:还刮吗
Others: Still scratching?
Jake:不刮了不刮了
Jake: No more, no more
Jake:呵呵呵呵
Jake: Haha
Jake:见好见好就收
Jake: Quit while you're ahead
Jake:见好就收
Shure: 我靠他居然见好就收
Shure: Wow, he actually quit while ahead
Jake:哼
Jake: Hmph
其他人:投资回报率也太低了
Others: The ROI is too low
Shure: 你想靠这个刷ROI是吗
Shure: You want to boost ROI with this?
Jake:你这是
Jake: What are you...
Lucia:说什么时候关门吗
Lucia: When are we closing?
Jake:现在就去吧
Jake: Let's go now
Shure: 现在就去快去
Shure: Let's go now, hurry
Jake:就是就在跑隔壁
Jake: Just run next door
Jake:早知道我们是7点多到
Jake: We should have arrived around 7
Jake:有30
Jake: Got 30
Jake:就一个30
Jake: Just one 30
Jake:就这头
Jake: Just this one
Jake:呃我是这么搞吗
Jake: Uh, am I doing this right?
其他人:不是
Others: No
Jake:好谢
Jake: Alright, thanks
其他人:哦这个这个这个
Others: Oh this, this, this
其他人:你是要相信运气的
Others: You have to believe in luck
Jake:谢可以在这继续走吧
Jake: Thanks, can I keep going here?
其他人:有些人就是一直买一个号
Others: Some people keep buying the same number
其他人:然后可能突然有一天没买就真的中
Others: And then one day they don't buy it and it actually hits
Shure: 这个
Shure: This one
Shure: 号很好
Shure: This number is good
Jake:就那排队的
Jake: Just the one in line.
Tasha:看到了
Tasha: Got it.
Jake:他就是在菜鸟驿站没有取
Jake: He didn't pick it up at the rookie station.
Jake:是吗
Jake: Right?
Jake:还是说还有别的地
Jake: Or is there another place?
Lucia:还有别的地儿
Lucia: There's another place.
Jake:别的地
Jake: Another place.
Lucia:新城有一个
Lucia: There's one in Xincheng.
Lucia:新城分布
Lucia: Xincheng distribution.
Lucia:还是啥呃我不是京东
Lucia: Or what's it... I'm not JD.
Lucia:那个雨轩是京东
Lucia: That Yuxuan is JD.
Shure: 京东关了啊
Shure: JD is closed.
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake:那你在这先排
Jake: Then line up here first.
Jake:我到前面看看去
Jake: I'll go check up ahead.
Jake:前面可能还有一个口
Jake: There might be another entrance up ahead.
Jake:还有一个
Jake: Another one.
Jake:哎走大路看不清楚
Jake: Hey, you can't see clearly on the main road.
Jake:是他妈在哪来着
Jake: Where the hell is it?
Jake:是有一个小豁口
Jake: There's a small opening.
Jake:这豁口里边有一个你记得不
Jake: Do you remember that there's something inside this opening?
Jake:就是我们
Jake: Just us...
其他人:哦那天后面去那个
Others: Oh, that day we went to the back.
Jake:对对对一堆保安那个
Jake: Yeah, yeah, a bunch of security guards.
其他人:一堆保安那个
Others: A bunch of security guards.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
其他人:从51往那个51往里走
Others: From 51, head inside from 51.
其他人:那个我不记得
Others: I don't remember that.
其他人:   那个我去过一次
Others: I went there once.
Jake:可能在这或者是在那
Jake: Maybe it's here or there.
Jake:那我先看一眼这然后要不就在那
Jake: Let me check here first, or maybe it's over there.
Jake:反正是在这附近
Jake: Anyway, it's nearby.
Jake:不在这
Jake: Not here.
Jake:找个人问问吧
Jake: Let's ask someone.
Jake:卧槽这他妈像吗这
Jake: Damn, does this look like it?
Jake:抓个人问问吧
Jake: Let's grab someone and ask.
Jake:美发找美发问问
Jake: Ask the hair salon.
Jake:您好您请问知道百世快递在哪取吗
Jake: Excuse me, do you know where to pick up Best Express?
Jake:啊百世快递搁哪啊
Jake: Uh, where's Best Express?
Jake:对就是好
Jake: Yeah, just... okay.
Jake:好吧谢谢你
Jake: Alright, thank you.
Jake:好谢谢好
Jake: Okay, thanks.
Jake:是这个吗
Jake: Is this it?
Jake:瞅一眼瞅一眼
Jake: Take a look, take a look.
Jake:哦哦哦OK我要去看一眼
Jake: Oh, okay, I need to check it out.
Jake:看哪都来了
Jake: Look, everyone is here.
Jake:继续走吧
Jake: Let's keep going.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:走位很像啊
Jake: The movement looks similar.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:这个我们怎么处理啊
Jake: How do we handle this?
Jake:哈哈哈回去要讨论讨论
Jake: Hahaha, we need to discuss this when we get back.
Jake:你这你这条
Jake: This, this one...
Shure: 其实我的眼睛处理方式很简单
Shure: Actually, my way of handling things is simple.
Shure: DELETE out哈哈哈
Shure: DELETE out, hahaha
Jake:那你刚才干嘛呢哈哈
Jake: Then what were you doing just now? Haha
Jake:直走左拐
Jake: Straight and then turn left.
Jake:啊这这个响这个响
Jake: Ah, this, this one is making noise.
Jake:这是快递站吗
Jake: Is this the delivery station?
其他人:不是那边
Others: No, it's over there.
Jake:还在前面哦哎
Jake: It's still ahead, oh, hey.
Jake:哎呀这咋这是有人还是没人呢
Jake: Oh, is there someone here or not?
Jake:有取快递
Jake: Anyone picking up deliveries?
其他人:是德邦的吗
Others: Is it from Deppon?
Jake:我不知道哈哈
Jake: I don't know, haha.
Jake:这个这边都什么时候关门
Jake: When do they close here?
其他人:你得看是不是德邦的
Others: You need to check if it's Deppon.
Jake:那那边还有吗
Jake: Is there another one over there?
其他人:前面有一个驿站
Others: There's a station up ahead.
Jake:啊我先瞅瞅我因为我不知道是什么
Jake: Ah, let me take a look first because I don't know what it is.
Jake:这是驿站吗
Jake: Is this a station?
其他人:不是
Others: No.
Jake:那驿站在哪啊
Jake: Then where is the station?
其他人:驿站应该在那边吧
Others: The station should be over there.
Jake:那边撞那边让我往这边跑
Jake: They told me to run this way.
Jake:这呵呵呵呵呵
Jake: This is... hahaha
其他人:你问问快递小哥
Others: Ask the delivery guy.
Jake:里边哪个
Jake: Which one inside?
Jake:他说里边有驿站吗
Jake: Did he say there's a station inside?
Jake:就那个是吧
Jake: Is it that one?
Jake:嗯进来了
Jake: Hmm, he came in.
Jake:不敢往前谢君主问
Jake: Doesn't dare to come forward, thanks to the monarch's question.
其他人:他没进来吧
Others: Didn't he come in?
Jake:嗯抽烟去了
Jake: Hmm, he went for a smoke.
Jake:真的他确实点好
Jake: Really, he's actually pretty good.
其他人:我总感觉他一天能吸
Others: I always feel like he can smoke
其他人:好多根啊
Others: a lot in a day.
Jake:啊他一天吸几根
Jake: Yeah, how many does he smoke a day?
Jake:他是现在越吸越多
Jake: Is he smoking more and more now?
Jake:还是
Jake: Or...
其他人:确实在越吸越多
Others: Yes, he's definitely smoking more and more.
其他人:确实我真以为大概一天只会吸两
Others: I really thought he would only smoke about two
其他人:三根两三根
Others: or three a day.
Shure: 那不是人家老烟民都是按盒吸的
Shure: But aren't the old smokers smoking by the pack?
Jake:低估人
Jake: Underestimate people.
Shure: 那肯定
Shure: Definitely.
Shure: 就像你喝咖啡就是越喝越没有用
Shure: Just like drinking coffee, the more you drink, the less effect it has.
Shure: 是一个道理
Shure: Same principle.
Shure: 他现在不止他可能
Shure: Now he's not the only one, maybe...
Jake:过过个两年
Jake: Give it a couple of years.
Shure: 让我们为他默哀
Shure: Let's have a moment of silence for him.
Shure: 啊祈祷
Shure: Ah, let's pray.
Shure: 对祈祷
Shure: Yes, pray.
Shure: 哈哈哈好AB
Shure: Hahaha, okay, AB.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha.
Jake:扎了一步
Jake: Took a step.
Shure: 我们这走到哪了
Shure: Where are we now?
Jake:哪的这个吗
Jake: Is it here?
Jake:哦好
Jake: Oh, okay.
Jake:我们绕了一圈是吧
Jake: Did we go in a circle?
Jake:我们应该有一个口人进来了
Jake: We should have an entrance.
Jake:因为我们不是绕了一圈吗
Jake: Because didn't we go in a circle?
Jake:然后如果我们从这边能出去的话
Jake: And if we can get out from here,
Jake:就把性命入大了
Jake: it would be huge.
Jake:然后咱就回来回去了
Jake: Then we can head back.
Jake:我们来看我们我嗯
Jake: Let's take a look at us, hmm.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:那打个电话问问
Jake: Let's make a call and ask.
Jake:来闻闻看
Jake: Come and smell it.
Jake:你先打喂喂
Jake: You call first, hello, hello.
Shure: 喂喂
Shure: Hello, hello.
Shure: 你们在那个百世的那个是什么快递啊
Shure: What kind of delivery service are you using with Best?
Shure: 百世的哎
Shure: Best, right?
Shure: 就是另一个
Shure: It’s the other one.
Shure: 另一个驿站应该是我的
Shure: The other station should be mine.
Shure: 是那个稍等一下
Shure: Wait a moment.
Shure: 你再你再单发我一下那个图片吧
Shure: Can you send me that picture again?
Shure: 行行好嘞好嘞拜拜
Shure: Alright, alright, thanks, bye.
Jake:小绿人
Jake: The little green man.
Shure: 你好 9-1-2563
Shure: Hello, 9-1-2563.
Jake:还有顺天快递
Jake: Also, Shun Tian delivery.
Jake:这么厉害
Jake: So impressive.
Shure: 呃也忘了是啥东西
Shure: Uh, I also forgot what it was.
Jake:你问他你是啥东西
Jake: Ask him what it is.
Jake:没了
Jake: That’s it.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Okay.
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go.
Shure: 是不是没有其他的了
Shure: Is there nothing else?
Shure: 没有的话我们就回去了
Shure: If not, we’re heading back.
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Jake:问问他们怎么走
Jake: Ask them how to get there.
Jake:哎关门了
Jake: Oh, it's closed.
Jake:电话走哪
Jake: Which way is the phone?
Jake:出去比较近那边
Jake: It's closer that way.
其他人:从这门
Other person: From this door.
Jake:好远远
Jake: So far away.
Jake:好谢谢谢谢
Jake: Okay, thank you, thank you.
Jake:好好好谢谢谢谢
Jake: Alright, alright, thanks, thanks.
Jake:没有劲道啊
Jake: No strength at all.
Shure: 哎我们把把两个女女生给丢那边了
Shure: Hey, we left the two girls over there.
Jake:那边那边还行
Jake: Over there is fine.
Jake:那边还有羊肉串吃
Jake: They have lamb skewers over there.
Jake:你把人拐这来
Jake: You brought them here.
Jake:倒是有点
Jake: That’s a bit...
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
其他人:太空站有空间
Other person: The space station has room.
其他人:太挤
Other person: Too crowded.
Jake:什么呀阿巴斯又怎么了
Jake: What happened with Abbas again?
Jake:空间站啊有空间
Jake: The space station has room.
Jake:搜
Jake: Search.
Jake:哇这什么东西
Jake: Wow, what's this?
Jake:杀鸡呢杀鸭杀驴
Jake: Killing chickens, ducks, and donkeys.
其他人:我的脑子还是不如弱智吧的人
Others: My brain is not as good as a simpleton's.
Shure: 你为什么非得要把它和你化为一类
Shure: Why do you have to classify it with yourself?
其他人:你这真是仙女
Others: You're really a fairy.
Shure: 你
Shure: You...
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Shure: 提高记忆力是吗
Shure: To improve memory, right?
Jake:提高逻辑能力
Jake: To improve logic skills.
Jake:逻辑推理能力
Jake: Logical reasoning skills.
其他人: 阿巴斯你知道吗太空有空间站
Others: Abbas, do you know there's a space station in space?
其他人:太挤就没空间站
Others: If it's too crowded, there's no space station.
其他人:太空有空间
Others: There's space in space.
其他人:有空空有空间站
Others: If it's empty, there's a space station.
其他人:太挤就没有空间站
Others: If it's too crowded, there's no space station.
Shure: 太挤就没有空间站
Shure: If it's too crowded, there's no space station.
Jake:哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Jake:我操
Jake: Damn.
Jake:我操得他妈写下来
Jake: Damn, gotta write that down.
Jake:车辆不上楼
Jake: Vehicles don't go upstairs.
Jake:火灾防范部跑错了
Jake: The fire prevention department ran the wrong way.
Jake:这啥呀
Jake: What's this?
Jake:可可以零线穿
Jake: Can it pass through the neutral line?
Jake:哎对头
Jake: Ah, right.
Jake:主要是多了个
Jake: The main thing is there's an extra...
Jake:多了个车
Jake: An extra car.
Jake:麦当劳早上那给人吃完呢
Jake: Did McDonald's finish serving breakfast already?
Shure: 饿死了
Shure: I'm starving.
Jake:那你可等
Jake: Then wait.
Jake:等更久行不行呵呵呵
Jake: Wait longer, is that okay? Hehehe.
Shure: 我可以边吃边等
Shure: I can eat and wait at the same time.
Jake:啊你吃饱了
Jake: Oh, you're full?
Shure: 没事我会留一点
Shure: It's okay, I'll leave some.
Jake:阿斯巴
Jake: Asba.
其他人:来北京记得打电话找我
Others: Remember to call me when you come to Beijing.
其他人:我提前把手机关机
Others: I'll turn off my phone in advance.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈我靠
Jake: Hahaha, oh my god.
其他人:你这声音听起来不像人的
Others: Your voice doesn't sound human.
其他人:嗓子能发出来
Others: Can your throat make that sound?
Jake:这不是嗓子发的应该
Jake: It's not coming from the throat.
Jake:啊哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
其他人:这哪肚子吗
Others: Is it from the stomach?
Shure: 嘴啊这
Shure: It's from the mouth.
Jake:哎这边有小门骗我们
Jake: Hey, there's a small door here tricking us.
Jake:啊啊啊
Jake: Ahhh
Shure: （歌词）fly me to the moon
Shure: (singing) Fly me to the moon
Jake:我靠我有个雕像呢
Jake: Wow, I have a statue!
Jake:我靠真他妈像
Jake: Wow, it really looks like it.
Jake:哈哈哈靠这大哥
Jake: Hahaha, this dude...
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Jake:或者他们自己回去也不是不可能
Jake: Or maybe they went back by themselves, it's possible.
Shure: 应该会在那等我们
Shure: They should be waiting for us there.
Jake:我觉得也是
Jake: I think so too.
其他人饿真饿
Others: So hungry, really hungry.
Shure: 那俩是吗
Shure: Is it those two?
Shure: 那俩不是
Shure: No, it's not those two.
Shure: 这不是我买的
Shure: This isn't what I bought.
Jake:棍
Jake: A stick.
Shure: 对一个圆形长条状物尺
Shure: Yeah, a round, long-shaped object, like a ruler.
Jake:哎呦我靠
Jake: Wow, damn.
Jake:过去过去过去
Jake: Go, go, go.
Jake:回去了啊
Jake: They went back.
Jake:或者吃串了
Jake: Or maybe they're eating skewers.
Shure: 不能吧
Shure: No way.
Jake:哈哈哈刮刮彩票去了
Jake: Hahaha, went to scratch lottery tickets.
Jake:晚了回去了
Jake: It's late, they went back.
Jake:咱也没知道他会
Jake: We didn't know they would.
Jake:哪个
Jake: Which one?
Jake:哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Jake:我们也觉得你们应该在刮彩票
Jake: We thought you guys were scratching lottery tickets.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Lucia:我刚接上你电话就网络异常又断了
Lucia: I just connected your call and then the network went down again.
Shure: 为你不接
Shure: Why didn't you answer?
Shure: 然后就给雨轩打
Shure: So I called Yuxuan.
Shure: 看人家秒接你怎么回事
Shure: See, they answered immediately, what's with you?
Shure: 反思一下
Shure: Reflect on it.
Lucia:是网络异常吗
Lucia: Is it a network issue?
其他人他网络怎么异嘛
Other: Why would the network act up?
其他人你他妈给你提这吧
Other: What the heck are you talking about?
其他人味太臭了
Other: The smell is awful.
Lucia:那我们俩运营商不一样呗
Lucia: Maybe we have different providers.
Jake:哈哈哈他怎么知道选那好的运营商
Jake: Haha, how does he know which provider to choose?
Shure: 那他怎么知道选那好的运营商
Shure: How does he know which provider to choose?
Shure: 你不知道呢
Shure: You don't know, do you?
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Lucia:不是你挑我运营商毛病
Lucia: It's not like you can criticize my provider.
Lucia:怎么不去跟运营商对质一下呢
Lucia: Why don't you take it up with them?
Lucia:是吧
Lucia: Right?
其他人呵又顶嘴了是吧
Other: Oh, talking back again, huh?
其他人又会顶嘴哈哈
Other: Always talking back, haha.
Lucia:哈哈你让他把这服务一改进一黑
Lucia: Haha, ask them to improve the service.
Lucia:我这接你电话就秒接是吧
Lucia: I'd answer your calls instantly then, right?
Lucia:哎呦又掉了啊
Lucia: Oops, it disconnected again.
Lucia:这玩意已经今天掉了无数次了
Lucia: This thing has disconnected countless times today.
Lucia:虽然从我拿上它到现在为止
Lucia: Even though I've had it for less than 10 minutes.
Lucia:还不超过10分钟
Lucia: It's been less than 10 minutes since I got it.
Shure: 没有共产党
Shure: Without the Communist Party... 政治问题
Jake:咱也拿点吧
Jake: Let's grab some.
Jake:给咱拿点
Jake: Get us some.
Jake:这个是
Jake: This is...
其他人大牌这是没有狐狸
Other: There's no fox.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Katrina: 狐狸在哪啊
Katrina: Where's the fox?
其他人很明显的狐狸哦这还有
Other: Clearly a fox, oh, there's more.
Jake:这是围巾
Jake: This is a scarf.
Jake:这是围巾吗
Jake: Is this a scarf?
Lucia:不是不是
Lucia: No, no.
Lucia:这是狐狸
Lucia: This is a fox.
其他人狐狸和狐狸的围巾好嘞
Other: Fox and fox scarf, alright.
Jake:这是个烟花吗
Jake: Is this a firework?
Jake:能买烟花吗
Jake: Can we buy fireworks?
Jake:买烟花吧
Jake: Let's buy fireworks.
Jake:买烟花放烟花
Jake: Buy and set off fireworks.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake:你们那里给放烟花吧
Jake: Can you guys set off fireworks there?
Jake:我不知道啊
Jake: I don't know.
Jake:南洋理工不能放
Jake: We can't put this at NTU
Jake:军事的管制区
Jake: It's a military controlled area.
其他人:但我看之前嘴也不是会放仙女棒啊
Others: But I've seen people use sparklers there.
Jake:仙女棒算什么东西
Jake: Sparklers are nothing.
Jake:呵呵呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehehehehe
其他人:所以我好奇
Others: So I'm curious.
其他人:现在他有人陪了
Others: Now he has someone to keep him company.
其他人:你们过年还会去
Others: Will you still visit during the New Year?
Jake:去啊去啊
Jake: Yes, yes, we will.
Jake:只有过年能见到他了
Jake: We can only see him during the New Year.
Jake:就是我老板
Jake: He's my boss.
Jake:就这个给钱的大老板
Jake: The big boss who pays us.
Jake:他这个谈恋爱之前天天跟我们吃饭
Jake: Before he started dating, he used to eat with us every day.
Jake:午饭和晚饭都够我们吃
Jake: Both lunch and dinner were on him.
Jake:谈恋爱之后就过年见着一次
Jake: After he started dating, we only see him during the New Year.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
其他人:所以他他不是刚谈吧
Others: So he just started dating, right?
Jake:没有他他女朋友从美国回来了对
Jake: No, his girlfriend came back from America.
其他人:居然是America
Others: From America, really?
Jake:不算是思科
Jake: Not exactly Cisco.
Jake:cisco
Jake: Cisco.
Lucia:你好有职业素养
Lucia: You're so professional.
Lucia:哈哈哈这段
Lucia: Hahaha, this part.
其他人:嗯可以不记这段
Others: Hmm, we don't need to record this part.
Shure: Cisco不能叫
Jake:美国那怎么说
Jake: What would you call it then?
Shure: 他应该叫*哈
Shure: It should be called the little Huawei of America, haha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Jake:这也太要紧了
Jake: That's way too much.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈不行吗
Jake: Hahahahahahahaha, isn't it?
Shure: 他不如华为啊
Shure: It's not as good as Huawei.
Shure: 不行吗行
Shure: Isn't it?
Jake:行没问题没问题
Jake: Yes, no problem, no problem.
Jake:硬件设备
Jake: Hardware equipment.
其他人:硬件设备供应商吗
Others: Hardware equipment supplier?
Jake:你华为做什么了
Jake: What does Huawei do?
Jake:他不做手机
Jake: They don't make phones.
Jake:除了别的
Jake: Besides other things.
其他人:这个华为不是
Other: Isn't this Huawei?
Jake:我靠那什么东西啊我靠
Jake: Oh my, what is that? Oh my.
Jake:行我们换个话题好吧
Jake: Alright, let's change the topic, okay?
Jake:呵呵呵呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehehe.
其他人:所以所以他
Other: So, so he...
Jake:所以
Jake: So...
其他人:他女朋友回来就要定居在新加坡了
Other: His girlfriend is going to settle in Singapore.
Jake:是吧哎呀
Jake: Right, oh dear.
Shure: 哎呀我今天晚上7点有个会啊
Shure: Oh dear, I have a meeting at 7 tonight.
其他人:牛逼还好
Other: Awesome, that's good.
其他人:像我会一般都安排到晚上10点半之后
Other: My meetings are usually scheduled after 10:30 PM.
其他人:可是我不会忘了
Other: But I won't forget.
Jake:啊你还要挣扎吗
Jake: Ah, do you still need to struggle?
Jake:他7点的会还要挣扎吗
Jake: Do you still need to struggle for the 7 o'clock meeting?
Jake:也不用了吧
Jake: Probably not, right?
Lucia:这不都7:46了吗哈
Lucia: Isn't it already 7:46?
Jake:对啊你还要挣扎吗
Jake: Yeah, do you still need to struggle?
Shure: 我是主持人
Shure: I am the host.
Shure: 我是社长啊哈哈哈
Shure: I am the president, hahaha.
Jake:哦有人找你是吧
Jake: Oh, someone is looking for you, right?
Lucia:那晚了大家已经等了你46分钟了
Lucia: Then you're late, everyone has been waiting for you for 46 minutes.
Jake:你说你你取快递
Jake: You say you, you went to pick up a delivery.
Katrina: 你耍大牌呀
Katrina: Are you showing off?
Jake:取快递取46分钟没问题
Jake: Picking up a delivery for 46 minutes, no problem.
Katrina: 迟到46分钟
Katrina: Late for 46 minutes.
Shure: 我刚才公司给我突然来了个电话
Shure: I just got a sudden call from the company.
Jake:对对都能走都能走
Jake: Right, right, everyone can leave.
Jake:换条新路
Jake: Take a new route.
Lucia:啥
Lucia: What?
Katrina: 他说Lisa给他派
Katrina: He said Lisa gave him...
Katrina: 活了他忙忘了
Katrina: ...some work, and he got busy and forgot.
Jake:嗯嗯确实
Jake: Mm, mm, indeed.
Katrina: 确实是啊
Katrina: Indeed, right?
Katrina: 丽丽让你出来取快递
Katrina: Lili asked you to pick up the delivery.
其他人:你这样说你就说啊
Other: Just say that.
其他人:刚才丽特给我呃安排了一下
Other: Just now, Lita arranged something for me.
其他人:明天我们要上线一个party
Other: We have a party going live tomorrow.
其他人:刚刚和同事们对齐了一下
Other: Just aligned with colleagues.
其他人:所以搞的比较晚
Other: So it got a bit late.
其他人:什么行业
Others: What industry?
其他人:黑花
Others: Hei Hua
Jake:呵你要说特殊情况
Jake: Heh, you want to talk about special circumstances
Jake:见着个狐狸
Jake: Saw a fox
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Jake:对对有点不巧
Jake: Yeah, yeah, a bit unfortunate
Jake:哎呦阿丽丽
Jake: Oh, Alice
其他人:我们我们往常是几点开始弄啊
Others: When do we usually start this?
Jake:晚上咱现在就在开始弄
Jake: At night, we're starting now
其他人:那那晚上一般几点钟弄完
Others: Then, what time do we usually finish at night?
Jake:这个很难讲
Jake: That's hard to say
其他人:还有一场吗
Others: Is there another session?
Jake:今晚没了
Jake: Not tonight
Jake:今晚就收拾收拾嘛
Jake: Tonight we just pack up
Jake:拆拆快递嘛
Jake: Unbox some packages
Jake:随便拍拍嘛
Jake: Take some random shots
其他人:那我约 10点半
Others: Then I'll make an appointment for 10:30
Jake:你可以约
Jake: You can make an appointment
Jake:你随便什么时候约
Jake: Anytime you want
其他人:是啊他爷爷不就说嘛
Others: Yeah, didn't his grandpa say
其他人:孩子长大了
Others: The kid grew up
其他人:等他回到家那个
Others: When he gets home
其他人:跟他回去
Others: Go back with him
其他人:台球啊哈哈
Others: Billiards, haha
其他人:我的台球是
Others: My billiards is
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Jake:啊工作不饱和啊
Jake: Ah, work is not saturated
Jake:工作不饱和
Jake: Work is not saturated
Jake:看着
Jake: Look
其他人:什么叫工作不饱和
Others: What do you mean by work is not saturated?
Lucia:还有时间打台球
Lucia: There's still time to play billiards
其他人:啊昨天已经过饱和了
Others: Ah, yesterday was already oversaturated
其他人:好嘞你知道我整个人都快要结晶了
Others: Oh, you know, I felt like I was crystallizing
Jake:呵呵你这是怎么讲
Jake: Haha, what do you mean by that?
Jake:脱水了是吗
Jake: Dehydrated, right?
Shure: 那个是那什么
Shure: That was, what was it
其他人:妈的台球海底捞
Others: Damn, billiards Haidilao
Jake:哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh
Shure: 台球海底捞
Shure: Billiards Haidilao
Shure: 你猜对
Shure: You got it right
其他人:台球海底捞
Others: Pool table hotpot
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh
其他人:这么牛逼啊
Others: That's awesome
Jake:多少钱多少钱
Jake: How much, how much?
其他人:也不贵不贵
Others: Not expensive, not expensive
其他人:就是正常价
Others: Just normal price
Jake:哎我们要拐了
Jake: Hey, we need to turn
其他人:那这种台阶
Others: These kinds of steps
其他人:都不会把别人杀的毫无还手之力
Others: Won't leave others defenseless
其他人:哎这边这边不往前走两下都行
Others: Hey, this way, this way. You don't need to move forward much
Lucia:还是停一下都行吗
Lucia: Can we stop for a bit?
其他人:都行吗要不就晚了
Others: It's fine, otherwise, it'll be too late
Jake:这边拐可以啊
Jake: We can turn here
Jake:那就这么拐吧
Jake: Let's turn this way then
其他人:百球小生会观察你
Others: The pool player will watch you
其他人:你要是这一球要用上加盖了
Others: If you need to use the cover for this shot
其他人:他主动帮你把加盖抬起来
Others: He'll help you lift the cover
其他人:我双手递给你
Others: I'll hand it to you with both hands
其他人:那加盖用完了
Others: After you finish with the cover
其他人:那双手递回来
Others: I'll hand it back
其他人:那别的排气
Others: For other things
其他人:那别的排球生存空间在哪呢
Others: Where's the living space for other players?
其他人:我不知道啊
Others: I don't know
其他人:我以后肯定只去银川
Others: I'll only go to Yinchuan in the future
其他人:太逆天了
Others: It's amazing
其他人:对于一个小城市出来的我
Others: For someone from a small town like me
其他人:我去哈哈哈
Others: I'm amazed, haha
Shure: 他那特贵
Shure: It's really expensive there
其他人:留下一部位
Others: Leave a place
其他人:留下金爷就比较会享受啊
Others: Leave it for Jin Ye, he knows how to enjoy
其他人:他说下次
Others: He said next time
Shure: 79一小时
Shure: 79 per hour
其他人:他说下次带我去个更好的地方
Others: He said he'll take me to a better place next time
其他人:哦不是你可以美谈美观啊
Others: Oh, you can enjoy it beautifully
其他人:确实今天要坐一下刘帅
Others: Today, we need to sit with Choiszt
其他人:让我让我看看刘帅开奔驰是什么样子
Others: Let me see what it's like when Choiszt drives a Benz
其他人:但是开奔驰的人会不会变帅
Others: But does driving a Benz make you look handsome?
其他人:我靠他那个后排的空间巨大
Others: Wow, the backseat space is huge
Shure: 我靠他那个后排的空间巨大
Shure: Wow, the backseat space is huge
Shure: 真就是给老板坐的巨爽
Shure: It's really comfortable for the boss to sit in
Shure: 而且你后排是可以瞧前排座椅的
Shure: And you can adjust the front seats from the back row.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Jake:哈哈哈哈好
Jake: Hahahaha okay
其他人:非常的人性化
Others: Very user-friendly
Shure: 不会像那个捷达你连找找都找不着
Shure: It's not like the Jetta where you can't find anything.
其他人:我的手就是找条达到胳膊
Others: My hand is just searching everywhere.
Shure: 一看就没开过
Shure: Clearly, you've never driven one.
Shure: 就是
Shure: Exactly.
Shure: 少爷就是没开过这种手动咔咔咔的车
Shure: You haven't driven a manual car like this.
Shure: 哎太金贵了少爷
Shure: Oh, you're too precious, man.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha
Jake:撞色
Jake: Contrasting colors.
Lucia:也行吧
Lucia: That works, I guess.
Jake:哈哈独特的设计
Jake: Haha, unique design.
Jake:给他唱一段
Jake: Sing a bit for him.
Jake:不像
Jake: Doesn't look like it.
其他人:喝酒喝吐了
Others: Drank until he puked.
其他人:只喝一分钟
Others: Only drank for a minute.
其他人:学英语交流
Others: Learning English through conversation.
Lucia:那只要沉默1分钟就好了
Lucia: Then just stay silent for a minute.
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Hehe.
Shure: 北方这边默认都不加什么糖什么东西
Shure: Up north, we don't add sugar or anything.
Shure: 然后
Shure: And...
Shure: 所以小时候就特不爱喝这种粥啥的
Shure: That's why I didn't like drinking this kind of porridge as a kid.
Jake:北极能看到星星
Jake: You can see the stars in the Arctic.
Shure: 通州沙河都能看到星星
Shure: You can see stars in Tongzhou and Shahe.
Jake:哦不是北京是吧
Jake: Oh, not in Beijing, right?
Shure: 哎能能能
Shure: Yeah, you can, you can.
Shure: 不不这算
Shure: No, no, it counts.
Shure: 北京这这场地也记一下
Shure: In Beijing, this place is also noteworthy.
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Shure: 他试图分裂北京
Shure: He's trying to divide Beijing. 政治问题
Jake:这哈哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake:就你这个迹象哈哈哈
Jake: Just like this, haha.
Jake:梅开二度
Jake: A second bloom.
Lucia:什么你是说我这个东西掉下来吗
Lucia: What, you mean this thing fell?
Jake:给一个给一个
Jake: Give one, give one.
Lucia:哦谢谢
Lucia: Oh, thanks.
Jake:谢谢没有没有
Jake: Thanks, no problem.
Jake:说他
Jake:美开2路
Jake: America opened route 2.
Lucia:哦
Lucia: Oh.
Jake:美开3路
Jake: America opened route 3.
Jake:帽子戏法了
Jake: It's a hat trick.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia:哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha.
Lucia:可是加个小不应该能
Lucia: But adding a small one shouldn't...
其他人:加个小波应该能
Others: Adding a small wave should work.
其他人:别说了别说了
Others: Stop it, stop it.
Jake:哈哈哈炸死你
Jake: Hahaha, blow you up.
Jake:哈哈喷他去
Jake: Haha, go spray him.
Jake:嗯嗯嗯
Jake: Mmm, mmm, mmm.
Jake:都行呵呵呵
Jake: Anything works, hehehe.
Jake:呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehehehehehehehehe.
Jake:走走了造吧哈哈
Jake: Let's go, let's go, let's create, haha.
Katrina: 这话简直难以置信哈哈
Katrina: This is simply unbelievable, haha.
Jake:总能总能到吧
Jake: We'll get there, we'll get there.
其他人:哎那边
Others: Hey, over there.
Jake:那边哎
Jake: Over there, hey.
Jake:回来了哈哈哈
Jake: He's back, hahaha.
Jake:不太行了
Jake: Not doing too well.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:悬崖勒马
Jake: Saved by the bell.
Jake:我去好香啊
Jake: Wow, it smells so good.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:确实来给你们吃
Jake: Indeed, come on, have some.
Jake:快递
Jake: Delivery.
Jake:什么货哦
Jake: What goods, oh.
Jake:吃吃汉堡吃蛋挞
Jake: Eat burgers, eat egg tarts.
Jake:吃什么呀
Jake: What to eat?
Jake:蛋挞是吧
Jake: Egg tarts, right?
Jake:好有什么好的吗
Jake: Alright, anything good?
Jake:有有有好的甜品吗
Jake: Are there any good desserts?
其他人:如果没有人点的就是我点的
Others: If no one ordered it, then I did.
其他人:但是我忘了你点的
Others: But I forgot what you ordered.
Jake:嗯吃两个呗
Jake: Hmm, let's have two then.
Alice:要吃个肉松小贝吗
Alice: Want to eat a pork floss cake?
Alice:好还是吃个菠萝小贝
Alice: Or a pineapple cake?
Jake:菠菠萝要
Jake: Pineapple, definitely.
Jake:可以要啊煎呗
Jake: Sure, fry it up.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:吃吃吃吃
Jake: Eat, eat, eat!
Jake:严谨严谨
Jake: Be precise, be precise.
Jake:吃点什么呢
Jake: What should we eat?
Jake:没关系盲盒麦当劳盲盒
Jake: No worries, mystery box McDonald's, mystery box.
Jake:对麦当劳盲盒
Jake: Yes, McDonald's mystery box.
Jake:因为路就很远
Jake: Because the road is very far.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.